τρίδα του και ήταν ένας άνθωπος που ήξερε και είχε όγαμα για την κύπο και
μαθα παρα πολλά πράγματα πρέπει να πό από τον τάσω εβελτίωσα και ταηληνικα μου τό
τον άλλον και έτσι είχαμε μια πολύ οραία ζωή καθε χόνο εφεύγαμε τα καλοκαιια επια
ένα με στι γαλία ε μετα παιδιά ααπούσε τη γαλία ήταν κάτι πουτο μιράτο μοιραζόμασταν
καιπείχε τακτες δύσκολε στιγμές του καιτες οραίας στιγμές του ταν κατάφερε να εκλίγει πρόεδώ στης
δημοκρατίας αλλά έχω νακλέγει και πρόερο της δημοκρατίας ένα πό ταβείτε που θυμάμε ήτα η
ιδική αναφορά που έκανε σε σας στη στήριξη που είχε αποεσας ναι νομίζω νε ότισε
αυτό τον τον στηρίξα όσον όσον εμποούσα βεβαίως αλλά αγαπούσα παγόλοπου δ γενήθηκα στην κύπρο
δεν μεγαλοσα στην κύπο αγαπούσω και αγαπό τον κόσμο της κύπχου και είμαι είμαι καλή
στων ακούο τον κόσμο το μαχρειάζεται κάποιος κάποια βοήθεια να βοηθώ και έτσι νομίζω ότι
ήταν κάτι που ήταν έμφιτο μέσα ου και πολύ για να αλλάξου για λίγο θέμα
πολύ είναι αυτή που λένε ότι βοηθάτε αλλά το κρατάτε πίσω από την πόρτα δν
έχετε την ανάγκηνα το διαφημήσετει σισαυικά όπως άλλους γιατί είναι πολύ ο κόσμος που βρίσκει
ένα καταφύγειω σησαή κ κοντά σας μια βοήθεια ναιεδώ και χρόνια ντάξει και μέσον του
ίδγου σταυγούαλλά κα από σας προσωπικά γι αυτό τονκαι μέσον του ιδρήματος βοηθούμε όσοπο αλλά